MARTIN GORNER: Hello,
and welcome back
on Root Access Berlin.
I'm here today with Ignacio
Coloma, the CTO of Koliseo.
IGNACIO COLOMA: Koliseo is a
start up that aims to make
ticketing a pleasant
experience,
as simple as possible.
MARTIN GORNER: So let
us hear a demo.
And here on the Koliseo website,
the nice thing is
that you have implemented
sign ins with
all possible accounts.
I will sign in with
my Google account.
And now, I want to
create an event.
So the Factory will be opening
its doors for the first time
in a couple of days.
And I want to invite people
to the factory opening.
In the next steps,
I can define the
details of my event.
I can also then create
tickets.
And you have a platform for
handling all the flow,
including registrations
on the venue itself.
IGNACIO COLOMA: That's it.
You can do can control how
the tickets are sold.
You can set the prices.
And you can also control the
access when the day comes.
You can go and be in charge
of the event.
And with your Android
device, you can just
check out the tickets.
MARTIN GORNER: All right.
So now tell me, Ignacio,
why did you
choose first App Engine?
And then also, you chose to use
a NoSQL database, the App
Engine Data Store, even if you
admitted that you had mostly
SQL background before?
IGNACIO COLOMA: That's right.
We come from a company with
a lot of SQL experience.
But for us, when we were
developing this project, we
wanted something that could
scale, and that had--
we wanted all the uptime,
but not the headaches.
We didn't want to be answering
calls from our
customers all day long.
So we wanted to try
something new.
MARTIN GORNER: And so yes, this
is something I hear a lot
from start-ups.
That they go with NoSQL because
it's fashionable.
And here, I would like to hear
your expert opinion and help
people decide rationally
between SQL and NoSQL.
So maybe we can try to come up
with a list of checks that you
can do against your project
requirements
to help people decide.
So the first thing to consider
is of course scalability.
Can you tell us more
about that?
IGNACIO COLOMA: When you're
talking about scalability in
the SQL world, the things are
more already thought out.
And the thing is you're
going to have,
let's say, one server.
Now, your server is going
to be scaling.
And at some point, you
will have to put
different servers as well.
And you have to decide if you
want to do vertical sharding
or horizontal sharding.
You have to decide if you're
going to go with master
replicates.
When you want to make your
databases scale, you have to
read a lot.
You have to read about the
last 20 years of SQL
databases, differentiate the
best practices from things
that are more or less outdated
or something.
With NoSQL, the thing is
you don't have this.
You have a data store that's
going to work from the
beginning and it's going to
scale for as many servers as
you like automatically.
Yes, you also have
a learning curve.
But it's much shorter.
It's more focused
on what matters.
MARTIN GORNER: So actually,
the App Engine Data Store,
which is one example of a NoSQL
database, what you say
is that it's multi-server
from the start?
IGNACIO COLOMA: Yeah.
MARTIN GORNER: And it basically
hides from you all
the multi-server complexity
that is powering it?
IGNACIO COLOMA: High
availability, load balance,
distribution of your data,
everything is taken care of
automatically.
You don't have to think
about that.
You don't have to
configure that.
It just works.
MARTIN GORNER: The second point
that I hear a lot from
people is that their feeling is
that NoSQL represents their
data in a more natural way.
Was that the case also
for Koliseo?
IGNACIO COLOMA: When you're
talking about SQL databases,
you have standard solutions
to standard problems.
So you're always watching your
problems with the same lenses.
Let's say for example
that you're talking
about the user account.
You have your user account.
And as you have seen, you can
have multiple OAuth providers,
so multiple credentials.
How you do that with
a SQL database?
MARTIN GORNER: So we tried to
represent on this slide here,
and I think you need
two tables, right?
IGNACIO COLOMA: Yes, right.
You need a master
details table.
And what you're going to do is
have a table with all your
users, and another one with
all your OAuth IDs.
And you're going to relate
one another.
With NoSQL, it doesn't
have to be that way.
You have other options.
You have multi-valued fields.
With multi-valued fields, the
same user can have multiple
values for the same field.
And you can handle that as
if it was a single value.
So the same way you would have a
user with a single OAuth ID,
for the same price, you can
have multiple values.
And you don't need a separate
table for that.
So for instance, here, my first
user, Bill K., has two
accounts with which he can
log in on to Koliseo.
And that means that any time I
want to return a user that has
a given OAuth ID, in SQL,
I have to do a join.
But also, whenever you
want to retrieve
users by any criteria--
let's say I want all my senior
users, like here, birth year
less than 1950--
then Bill K. will come up
twice in the results.
Because the join actually
created two Bill K's, one Bill
K. that has a Google provider,
and one Bill K. that had a
Facebook provider.
So now, when I handle those
users, I have to handle those
duplicates.
MARTIN GORNER: Yeah, that's
a common problem.
And what I hear from people on
a philosophical level is that
they like the fact that in a
NoSQL database, a user entity
has its identity, it has its
key, and you know exactly
where your user is.
IGNACIO COLOMA: Yeah, it's
conceptually simpler because
you have a single entity
with multiple values
for the OAuth IDs.
But you don't have to mix IDs
just because of the data store
you're using.
In that sense, it's
much simpler.
MARTIN GORNER: So a brief
introduction about the code
snippets that we will be seeing
during this episode.
When making Koliseo, you also
made Simple DS, which is an
access layer for the App Engine
database that allows
you, correct me if I'm wrong,
that allows you to represent
your database entities
using Java objects.
IGNACIO COLOMA: Yeah,
that's right.
You can get all the mapping
between Java and the data
store into this.
And you can match
and mix between.
And you can use also a JSON
representation, or nested objects.
It takes care of all of that.
It's a little bit
like Objectify.
You also have that in
the Java world.
It came out more less at the
same time as Simple DS.
MARTIN GORNER: So on
scalability, NoSQL wins.
On the way of representing
data, the philosophical
argument is that NoSQL kind
of wins, although you
can argue both ways.
And now, the engineers designing
NoSQL databases also
had to sacrifice some things.
So let's talk about that.
And first of all, maybe what is
really super nice about SQL
databases is that they have
the SQL language.
Anything I write that is
syntactically correct will
execute, maybe slowly, maybe
using all of my memory.
But it will execute.
It will return results.
IGNACIO COLOMA: Yeah,
I missed that a lot.
You don't have that in NoSQL.
Some of the queries that you
can imagine won't execute
because you're using
incompatible ways of querying
the data store.
For example, you cannot query a
"different than." You cannot
query values different than
two, for example.
MARTIN GORNER: Even before
that, even if you want to
query by inequality, value
equals something, you need an
index on that value.
IGNACIO COLOMA: Yeah.
If you're going to launch a
query, you need an index for
everything that is inside
of that query.
For example, if you are querying
for a single value,
then you need an index
for that value.
If you need two values in the
same query, then you need a
composite index for
these two values.
Also, if you're sorting, sorting
by a value, querying
by another value, you need a
composite index for that, too.
And that's sometimes a problem
because every time you're
inserting, you're inserting
the values, and also each
index that you're adding.
So sometimes, it's more the
effort of writing the indexes
than it is writing
actual data.
MARTIN GORNER: Yes, and also,
based on the queries that you
want to run, you have to
organize your data in specific
ways when you use a
NoSQL database.
IGNACIO COLOMA: Yeah, sometimes
you have to plan in
advance, how am I going to
query this data before
you can design it.
So how am I going to organize
my entities?
Which indices am
I going to use?
Sometimes, you have to
reorganize your data to be
able to execute this other way
of querying this information,
this feature or whatever.
You need to do that.
But that's also common
with SQL databases.
At some point, they're
also refactored.
So it's no news for any of us.
MARTIN GORNER: But that is where
database schemas come in
in SQL databases.
When I want to add a new field,
I do one command, which
is alter table, and I have
a new column in my table.
If you want to do this in a
NoSQL database, it's slightly
more complicated.
IGNACIO COLOMA: Yeah.
If you want to modify your
existing data in NoSQL
databases, you have to iterate
over all the existing records,
adding new fields, removing
existing fields, whatever, to
get what you would do with
a single command with SQL
databases that would be
alter table, and it's
automatically there.
MARTIN GORNER: And also, if I
have a large project based on
SQL, usually I have a database
administrator who is the
guardian of my schema.
And he locks it down to prevent
random rogue engineers
from adding random rogue fields
wherever they see that
they would like to have them.
IGNACIO COLOMA: Yeah, you won't
have that in NoSQL.
For example, you wouldn't have
a referential integrity.
So I can modify data by hand and
leave the data store in an
inconsistent state.
That can happen.
You are not forced to have the
same structure in all your
entities at all.
And sometimes, that's good
because, for example, you have
data that depends on the
kind that it has.
I have one field, or I don't
have this field.
I have a different field.
You can use that to
your advantage.
Or you can just use, in our
case, in Java, you have your
persistent classes.
And that defines the properties
that you have.
You can use it, or
not, as you like.
MARTIN GORNER: So that would
be another win for SQL, the
presence of database schemas.
And the last point that
I would like us
to discuss is coherence.
NoSQL being multi-server by
default, that is probably
where the trade-offs
are the strongest.
Let's distinguish two different
types of coherency,
first the coherency
of transactions.
On a transaction, you
want to be asset.
And you always want
to be asset.
There is no trade-off there.
But to run a transaction on a
NoSQL database, you have to do
something special.
IGNACIO COLOMA: Yeah, concretely
in the App Engine
Data Store, you have
entity groups.
Entity groups are based
on that parent child
relationship model.
So you define your parent.
And everything that is handing
from the parent, all of that
shares the same transaction.
MARTIN GORNER: And so you have
to put all your entities into
one entity group before you can
run a transaction on that
entity group?
IGNACIO COLOMA: It's more
that you make clusters.
All the entities are a cluster
are going to be part of that
transaction.
That was originally the only way
you had in App Engine to
do transactions.
Actually, now it's more
flexible, and now you can make
cross-group transactions, XE
transactions that can put up
to five different entity
groups in the same
transaction.
MARTIN GORNER: And also, the
fact that you put entities
into one transaction group, that
severely limits the rate
at which you can write to that
transaction group, right?
IGNACIO COLOMA: Yup.
You have a limited rate of, I
think, it's something like one
to five writes per second.
MARTIN GORNER: So that's
very long.
IGNACIO COLOMA: Yeah,
actually.
And you can create a
great [INAUDIBLE]
there.
If you have a lot of users
trying to push their
transactions in the same
transaction group-- if it's
different transaction
groups, it's fine.
But if it's in the same
transaction group, you have a
limitation there.
MARTIN GORNER: Briefly, I would
like to mention a second
type of coherency, which is
the read your own writes
coherency, which in
the SQL world,
again, is usually exact.
And here in the NoSQL world,
it can happen that
you send the right.
And even reads that come after
it still see the old value
until a certain point in time
where the new value will
become visible.
So it's called eventual
consistency.
IGNACIO COLOMA: Yes,
that's right.
MARTIN GORNER: Was that
a problem for you?
IGNACIO COLOMA: Not usually.
It's not usually a problem
because we are talking about
one second of time between I
do the change, and all the
queries in the world that are
going to see that change.
There's always that small gap.
Maybe your listing, your user
listing, is going to be one
second outdated.
That's not a big deal.
MARTIN GORNER: So it's
something you
have to know about.
But in your opinion, that was
actually a good thing, a good
constraint to relax?
IGNACIO COLOMA: Yeah, yeah.
MARTIN GORNER: Let's recap
here the five points.
On scalability, NoSQL wins.
I think we all agree on that.
On the way you can structure
your data--
IGNACIO COLOMA: Multiple
valued fields
is a big win here.
And I really don't miss
all those things.
But yes, we were talking before,
maybe that's a problem
for some heavy users.
MARTIN GORNER: Yes, but on the
other hand, SQL is a great
language if you have a DB admin
enforcing strong schemas.
That is something you will
miss in the NoSQL world.
And the way you run transactions
in NoSQL involves
slightly more work than
in the SQL world.
IGNACIO COLOMA: Yeah.
MARTIN GORNER: All right, thank
you very much, Ignacio.
And we will be seeing you again
in the next episode.
In the next episode, we'll have
tips and tricks to help
you overcome some of those NoSQL
limitations so that you
can take advantage of the power
of NoSQL and still work
around the limitations.
IGNACIO COLOMA: Yup,
that will be fun.
MARTIN GORNER: So we'll
see you next time.
Thank you very much, Ignacio,
for being with us.
IGNACIO COLOMA: Thanks.
MARTIN GORNER: Thank you for
watching Root Access Berlin.
Goodbye.
IGNACIO COLOMA: Bye.